في اواخر يوليو واوائل اغسطس من العام
2001 كانت جزيره صقليه الايطاليه على موعد
ما حدث مهيب لم تشهده البلاد منذ عام الف
وتسعمائه
عندما ضربتها سلسله من الزلازل انتهت
بثوران بركان كبير خلف مئات القتلى والاف
المشردين فماذا حدث
خلال الشهور السته الاولى من ذلك العام
ضربت جزيره صقليه الايطاليه سلسله من
الزلازل تركز اغلبها في شمال مدينه
نيكولوسي التي تشهد نشاطا بركانيا منذ
مئات السنين حيث يقع جبل اتنا الذي يوصف
باسمي جبل النار
ما حلول السابعه عشر من يوليو احدثت
الهزات الارضيه ثلاثه شقوق كبرى بجبل اتنا
مع اعتبر ايذانا رسميا ببدايه الثوران
الفعلي لاعلى بركان في ايطاليا
سارعت وسائل الاعلام لالتقاط صور مباشره
للحدث المهول وتناقلت الشاشات لقطات مريعه
لالسنه النيران وهي تتصاعد من الجبل
في الثاني والعشرين من يوليو كانت هناك
خمس فتحات بركانيه جديده تنفث الحمم
البركانيه على ارتفاعات عاليه بلغت عند
الذروه نحو 2720 مترا ما كان كافيا لتدمير
ابراج التلفريك قرب المرتفعات
تدفقت الحمم البركانيه على مدار عده ايام
نحو مدينه نيكولوسي والقرى المحيطه بها ما
دفع البعض للظن بان المدينه حكم عليها
بالفناء وان سكانها انتهوا بقبضه البركان
لكن سرعه الحمم تباطات مع اقترابها من
المدينه وهدات عند مسافه خمسه كيلو مترات
رغم ذلك دمرت الصخور المنصهره الجاريه
العديد من المباني والمرافق حيث اشتعلت
النيران في منتصف الطريق فوق منحدرات
البركان الاكبر والاكثر نشاطا في اوروبا
كما عبرت فوق ابراج التزلج ومواقف
السيارات والمرافق السياحيه التي تزخر بها
المنطقه
اعلنت حاله الطوارئ في اجزاء واسعه من
صقليه حيث تم اجلاء اربعين الف شخص ممن
اصبحوا بلا ماوى الى مخيمات ميدانيه كما
تم تامين عشره الاف اخرين في فنادق على
الساحل
في محاوله لتبريد الحمم التي بلغت درجات
حرارتها نحو الف درجه مئويه عملت القوات
المحليه على اسقاط الاف الاطنان من المياه
عن طريق الجو تدخل الجيش بالمعدات الثقيله
وكافح عمال الانقاذ لتحويل مسار الحمم
البركانيه فيما لجا السكان المحليون
لاقامه الابتهالات الدينيه
لقي
318 اشخاص حتفهم فيما تم تشريد 28 الف
شخصا في 26 مدينه وبلده متضرره كما تم
تدمير ما بين ثلاثه الاف11 الف مبنى في
المدينه القديمه قدرت الخسائر في قطاعي
السياحه والزراعه وغيرهما بقيمه ثلاثه
ملايين ومئه الف دولار
هبت العديد من الدول والمنظمات والشركات
والمشاهير للمساعده فيما منحت الحكومه
الايطاليه اعفاءات ضريبيه ل 300 اسره
متاثره وقدمت اكثر من خمسه ملايين الف
جنيه استرليني مساعدات ماليه فوريه كما تم
تخصيص نحو ثمانيه ملايين دولار لمشروعات
الانعاش في المنطقه
رغم انه يملك واحدا من اطول السجلات
الموثقه للبراكين بالعالم لم تكن كارثه
جبل اتنى الشاهق فوق كتانيا ثاني اكبر
مدينه في صقليه هذه المره مثل اي مره
فالاحجار البازلتيه التي غطت بياض الثلوج
فوق سفح الجبل ستبقى توثق ذكرى هذه
الكارثه المريعه للابد